more green juice okay hey everyone I'm
Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen so as my
channel has really evolved over the
years I've seen a huge uptick in my
plant-based followers so of course as a
result I've really made an effort to
make more recipes for you guys who are
looking for some more vegan and play at
base recipes also in my own life I just
have found that I've transitioned to
eating more plant-based foods just you
know for a variety reason I'll talk
about but also the fact that it's kind
of being a nice challenge for me to play
with ingredients that I didn't
necessarily grow up with eating in a
very kind of mean potatoes British
household so that's been really fun to
me
and you know I'm sure godus will will
will come at me for this but I think the
benefits of eating more plant-based
foods is hard to dispute
so one there's of course the
sustainability and the environmental
considerations in fact drawdown which is
a world-class research organization that
analyzes global climate solutions named
eating a plant-based diet number four in
their suggestions on improving climate
change I also think it's pretty clear
from the evidence that eating more
plant-based foods can help reduce the
risk of a wide range of chronic diseases
including colon cancer cardiovascular
disease type 2 diabetes and more finally
of course for those who are concerned
about animal cruelty eating fewer animal
products means less animals die whether
or not you can do that in a humane way
of course is up for debate also I want
to point out that despite what the
internet trolls may say dietitians like
myself are not controlled by the meat
dairy industries in fact the Academy of
Nutrition and Dietetics has come out and
said that a well-planned vegan or
vegetarian diet can be healthful
nutritionally adequate and may have
benefits that can help prevent or treat
chronic diseases so with all that said
why don't I just go vegan
well simply put any kind of restrictive
set of food rules is just not healthy
for me given my history of disordered
eating so I've told my or threat SIA
story in my book the my flow cookbook
but every single day now I'm getting DMS
and comments on my youtube channel and
emails from all of you telling me about
your relationship with food and your
struggles that you're having in this
kind of wellness culture that we're
currently living in especially when it
comes to social media and the pressures
around that so I really felt like I
wanted to take some time to tell my
orthorexia story here on my channel as
well
so when I was like 17 years old or so I
just graduated from high school and I
sought out the help of a homeopathic
practitioner to help me with some basic
kind of digestive issues so gas bloating
digestive kind of pain or discomfort all
the kinds of things that we're talking
and hearing about all the time on the
internet especially on YouTube and her
suggestion of course was to go on
basically like a sugar detox cutting out
all the sugars in my diet even the
natural stuff so I had always had like a
generally balanced healthy diet I never
really thought that much about food I
had never really dieted my my diet
consisted of like a very healthy balance
sometimes there were turkey burgers with
salad sometimes there were grilled
vegetables with a little steak or you
know pasta or slice of pizza
I never overdid it I never felt the need
to kind of binge I never obsessed over
what I was eating I just was eating
ultimately intuitively even though I
didn't have a name for it then I just
was eating what felt good to my body so
my diet went from being relatively
well-balanced to a handful of really
restrictive clean eating food so big big
salads without dressing and steamed
vegetables galore grilled chicken
breasts and other really lean proteins
plain no sauce sugar free jello or other
kind of diet e products like that and so
yeah I I what started out as a desire to
kind of kick a sugar habit very quickly
spiraled into an overwhelming obsession
and fear of all foods that I did not
consider clean or healthy and so this is
what orth Rexy is all about really
orthorexia is an obsession with clean
eating with with healthy eating and
unlike other eating disorders like
anorexia where the concern is really on
quantity of food with with orthorexia
it's all about quality or perceived
quality right it's it's all about kind
of eliminating those toxins or unclean
foods from your diet and even though it
wasn't about whey
los for me weight loss was never the
goal when I was eating such a such a
small selection of foods and and
low-calorie foods at that I actually
shed about 50 pounds on my already you
know pretty small natural frame and the
only thing more scary and [ __ ] up
about that than the fact that like I'm
really lucky to be alive right now
is the fact that I was constantly being
praised for my ultimately malnourished
body and my commitment to clean eating
honestly I can't tell you how many times
that people would you know pat me on the
back end because they saw what I was
eating and tell me how good I was being
and how bad they had been the night
before for eating a Snickers bar so
basically what I was being taught as a
young seventeen year old girl was that
my moral value was based on the food I
was choosing to eat and my emaciated
controlled body so anyways at the same
time I was really falling into this
anti-social cycle where my own fear of
not having control over what I was gonna
be able to eat and my embarrassment over
my disappearing body maybe not want to
go out with friends or make friends but
at the same time you know being isolated
and and eating by myself only enabled my
eating disorder and my mind assorted
behaviors and my depressive thoughts so
for those of you who have struggled with
disordered eating you know that it's a
lot easier for you to get away with it
when you're doing so in isolation and
nobody's standing over your shoulder
being like eat that and now is 15 years
ago
scarily today with the rise in
popularity of clean eating and wellness
diets a lot of those things that I've
been talking about so much here on the
abbeys kitchen channel one of these
disordered eating behaviors have become
synonymous with moral superiority and
economic privilege and social class in
other words it's become cool to eat
clean I mean you can't really even go
out for dinner anymore with friends
without somebody talking about their new
or detox it's like we're trying to
one-up each other on the moral value
scale by restricting harder or more
things and even if you don't have
friends in real life who participate
it's really easy to find your community
online to help perpetuate your
disordered beliefs and behaviors now I
want to take this back for a second just
to reiterate that I'm not suggesting
that veganism causes orthorexia I'm not
saying that I've talked about that
before that is not my intention here
however there is a fine line sometimes
between wanting to eat healthy however
you want to define that and orthorexia
which is why for me you know for the
longest time it took so long for me to
even recognize that there was an issue
here because in my mind I was just doing
what was best for me and for my health
and from all the comments that I've seen
this concept is so pervasive I'm seeing
this in so many of the experiences that
you all have been sharing with me that
is the wellness diet promise but if
you're curious where your intentions lie
it really comes down to being inflexible
if the thought of going out to dinner
without knowing you know what's gonna be
served or how its prepared or not being
able to control the menu your way sends
you into a panic mode you may have a
problem if your diet starting to
interfere with your emotional
psychological and social well-being you
might have an issue you might be in the
best king shape of your life and still
in a health crisis you honestly cannot
judge a book by its cover this is why
even though I see environmental animal
welfare and health base reasons to go
plant-based I cannot and will not ever
be able to follow a strict vegan diet
same would go for things like a keto
diet or paleo we're in a train fasting
or whatever even though it may be well
intentioned and grounded in wellness I
know that having to follow a strict set
of rules would trigger my or x'q
tendencies and lead me back down that
dangerous road that I worked so hard to
get out of I also get that a lot of you
who practice a vegan diet will claim
that you know this is not
about our help it's about the health and
well-being of the animals and I totally
understand that I get that however this
might just be a difference in values but
I feel that I need to value and
prioritize my own health and well-being
over that of the animals in this case
some of you may not need to make that
choice and that's great but just based
on my own personality and history I know
that I do and I have to prioritize my
own well-being
so let's talk about my diet how I eat
and what works for me now I know that
people like rules they like categories
they like black and white
I mean Society has taught us that we
need these external regulators to help
us make decisions about our health and
what to eat but I have spent the better
part of a decade trying to learn how to
become comfortable with the gray and get
back in tune with my body through
intuitive eating so what tends to work
well for me is just eating foods that
feel good to my body make me feel
satisfied without the need for explicit
labels I mean you could technically call
me kind of like a flexitarian but I even
reject that because I'm honestly just
eating in a way that feels good to me in
that moment meal or day so usually that
means eating a lot of plants with some
dairy fish poultry or meat in modest
portions I tend to feel most satisfied
with some animal proteins and end
products in my diet but more importantly
I think just not having those strict
rules means I don't feel like repressed
or restrained in a way that makes me
just emotionally want to bounce between
two extremes which I know would be my
tendency if I impose these really strict
rules honestly if I went strictly vegan
I would be concerned that I would very
quickly become unbeaten and be eating
raw duck breasts in the back of a cab
like this guy no but seriously I could
never do that but I do know that it's
just not emotionally healthy for me I
also believe that a lot of the benefits
for the environment animal welfare and
for our health can actually be achieved
simply by consuming more plant-based
products and consuming animal products
in more modest ways so for example if we
just thought of meat more like a side
dish rather than always being the main
event or more kind of like a garnish for
example on a dish to complement beans
and legumes and pulses we probably
wouldn't have to rely so heavily on
factory farming we would be able to
enjoy the antioxidants and fiber found
in plant-based foods and we could still
participate in some of the social and
all activities that involve animal based
products I'm not here to preach to
anyone to change their diet I mean you
do what works best for you only you are
the expert in your own body but I really
just want to reiterate that I want
Abbey's kitchen to be a respectful place
for a variety of diets and for everyone
to eat in ways that feels intuitive and
healthy for them so if my story rings
bell for you and you feel like you may
be struggling with your relationship
with food into sort of eating we're
gonna leave some really great resources
in the description so definitely check
that out I would also love to hear any
kind of resources or strategies things
that have helped you along in your
journey to intuitive eating and having a
better relationship with food please a
reminder to everybody let's be
respectful on this video in the comments
section I do not want any diet hate
going on so let's keep it clean but of
course if you like this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up leave me a comment
below like I mentioned subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]